this is uh me cutting off Clay Matthew's
head here his corpse and then we're
cutting these uh Packer lineman's next
with the ax and we got this one his
skull as Crush there this is me and face
paint with Aaron Rodgers head on a spear
it looks like Aaron Rodgers
yeah his mustache and [ __ ] then we go
back here this is one of my first
ex-wife
then if you're going around to this arm
here
we got the Flames I'm fighting a lion
here stabbing a lion we got this lion's
head cut off with the spine drip and
blood like Mortal Kombat there's my
daughter with the little baby lions
adding it
we got a dragon that's ripping through
the skin here setting the whole arm on
fire and then we got my family here's my
brother who got like a viking zombie in
the Flames there we've got the Viking
logo
and then we got a valkyrie with a dragon
and my daughter is feeding a bear's head
to the Dragon
and we got uh Drew Brees full of arrows
we got Eli Manning and Ben
Roethlisberger
and uh yeah that's about it